MICHAEL CIMA: Chemistry is
not an abstract concept to me.
It's the most important tool in my
toolkit to come up with new inventions.
And that's what I do day
in and day out at MIT.
I'm Michael Cima.
I've been at MIT for 25 years.
I'm an educator, researcher,
mentor, and an inventor.
The course that I'm working
on at MIT is called 3091x.
It's an introduction to
solid state chemistry.
It's been taught at MIT as
a GIR for over 40 years.
And it's an extremely unique course.
You can't get this course
anywhere else in the world.
Our goals for 3091x are a very simple.
We want you, at the end of this
course, to know all the same, exactly
the same, chemical principles you would
in any university chemistry course,
except that you've learned them from
the point of view of the solid state.
The examples we use have to do
with the solids, the materials,
that you work with every day.
And that's important, because our
hypothesis is that it's easier for you
to understand and to use
these chemical concepts
if you can relate them to
the materials around you.
Understanding of solid state principles
has transformed all of our lives.
I'm 53 years old.
In my lifetime, I've
witnessed everything change,
from communications,
transportation, energy, everything.
And it all has been,
at its heart, centered
on discoveries in the
solid state sciences.
If you think about
semiconductors, for instance,
the basic concepts of what
makes semiconductors work
are the kind of thing we study in 3091.
The chemical concepts
that make semiconductors
work that are at the heart of the
information age are what we study.
Teaching a class at MIT is a little
bit different than anywhere else
in the world.
And teaching it through 3091x
is going to be different also.
But the most important rule that I use
is, we don't actually teach anything.
We help you discover something.
And so the rule that we'll have
in building the 3091x platform
is, how do we help students
discover solid state chemistry.
Not teach them anything, but guide
them through their own discovery
of what, I think, is a
very important science.